Denise and Brian this comes as Robert
Tallis waits for his next court
appearance here at the Clark County
Detention Center I spoke with the
executive editor of the review journal
tonight and he tells me while they why
they filed this motion this week
Jeff's Legacy is of
Fearless determined Relentless reporting
Glenn cook executive editor of the Las
Vegas Review Journal remembers
investigative reporter Jeff gearman a
month after his murder we're all
grieving and we're all hurting over the
loss of a trusted friend and colleague
and with that grief comes a continued
journalistic effort it's at this point
about making sure that his murder
does not do anything to compromise our
ability to tell important stories on
Tuesday the review journal filed this
temporary restraining order blocking the
state and Metro Police from searching
gearman's computers and phones seized
after his death we're in unchartered
territory on multiple fronts here cook
says any information not related to the
case of Robert Tellis who is accused of
murdering Jeff should be off limits
under Nevada's reporter's Shield law we
can't allow them to learn the identities
of important confidential sources inside
those agencies the latest way gearman's
friends and colleagues are doing their
best to honor who he was and the kind of
determination and relentlessness that he
brought to the way he did his job is I
think going to inspire future
generations of journalists
I did reach out to the district
attorney's office regarding this case a
representative did get back to me and he
said he does expect to hear back from
D.A Wolfson on this tomorrow now as for
that full motion that document filed
this week we have a look at the entire
thing on our website eightnosenow.com
reporting live tonight Sasha Loftus 8
News Now